what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with uh iron man by christopher
cantwell the books of corvac conclusion
now a little bit of catching up here
right because it's been a little while
it's been like three or four months
since we finished issue finished the
last volume because it took three or
four months for this one to finish so
the thing about this is iron man
basically has the power of galactus
right the power cosmic and what he did
is he had essentially used his power to
make everybody in the world as smart as
him except for reed richards who
actually got dumber because he was on
the same level intelligence as tony
stark so what this did is it led to a
handful of different things at the
outset it didn't seem like the worst
thing ever because suddenly humanity was
just achieving all these incredible you
know monumental things that otherwise
would have been virtually impossible so
teachers using science and technology
and average kids and so on and so forth
and so what we end up getting here is
kind of how things ended up going dark
relatively fast and so what we find out
of course we have this reporter who says
the tri-state region continues to see a
surge in intellectual abilities just
days after tony stark recently imbued
with cosmic power exponentially raised
the collective brain power of every new
york city citizen already 34 separate
diseases four of them terminal have been
cured by physicians at the manhattan
city hospital eleven other illnesses
have also been eradicated by three taxi
drivers one short order cook and a
septic plumber that the city's landfill
has been converted into a newly
discovered renewable fuel source dubbed
refusium things like this are benefiting
society as a whole the other side though
and the caveat to this is that the stock
market has been massively destabilized
by an influx of traders manipulating
data in ways never before comprehended
by banks and brokerage houses this has
sparked a major international sell-off
and could risk a steep recession in the
united states compounding economic
turmoil is the robberies at five
separate flagship bank branches in the
city including the federal reserve gold
vault all by what authorities are
calling exceptionally brilliant and
gifted feasts and so not everybody with
this exceedingly high level of
intelligence has actually started using
it to benefit society some people are
using it to benefit themselves more so
than that one of the other things we're
told is that much of new york's law
enforcement has recently fallen to the
iron god to iron man and other heroes
since nearly the entirety of the nypd
has banded together to form their own
private space program called blue moon
literally they took off to the moon so
like those are the kind of things that
you're running into society is for the
most part falling apart because
everybody's using this level of
intelligence for their own end some
people are using it to make themselves
richer some people are using it to make
the world better but for those who are
using it for their own selfish ends it's
destabilizing society because seemingly
everybody thinks they're the first one
to think of this novel concept and so
what you end up getting is patsy walker
again the closest confidant of iron man
at the moment who brings in victor von
doom and the reason for this is because
what victor von doom had done as soon as
tony stark had arrived on scene that
doom had come to the realization stark
would do something like this and so of
course using magic shielded himself from
the effects of tony stark's you know
manipulation his energy and so for the
most part everybody else kind of remains
unscathed the other part of this is that
what tony stark has done here you know
following the arrival of the silver
surfer at least as far as patsy walker
was concerned you know requesting his
aid is that tony stark is really
succumbing to his own power in the sense
that what it would what you would need
with a person of this level of power is
to essentially be benevolent they
couldn't really bend to their own
individual wishes that is not tony stark
that has never been tony stark
and so literally where he's beset on all
sides by all these people who are in you
know stark industries telling him of the
lawsuits that he's getting and all these
different things how everything's just
kind of going nuts right the mayor's
office being flooded with calls and all
that kind of stuff then he basically
gets tired of the whole thing snapping
his fingers using his power everybody's
congratulating him you're doing such a
great job tony stark all of this is
awesome so in reality he's ignoring the
reality of the situation and replacing
it with his own he's like us on the
internet right like i reject your
reality and substitute it with my own if
the world's not the way that i want it
to be then i can just recreate it in my
own little sphere of influence and
ignore reality as it really exists and
so because of that tony stark's really
just kind of going off the rails now
he's not going crazy it's not like he's
losing his mind and it's just destroying
the earth or anything like that but it's
small little things like these that
people are concerned about specifically
what's left of those who are unaffected
that are they're worried about tony
stark going off the rails and ultimately
destroying everything and so what they
end up doing is in effect creating a
kind of cosmic weapon of sorts that can
basically strip them of its power or at
least siphon it off and so you get a bit
of a distraction here right now one of
the things that goes on of course you've
got patsy walker who asks uh doctor doom
if you want some pizza or if you'll grab
napkins and he's like i will not carry
any napkins i'm gonna be honest with you
guys i kind of want to see what i like i
wanted to see a moment where she offered
doctor doom like you want sausage or
pepperoni and he's like doom does not
suffer pepperoni
doom will take supreme or nothing else
you know like i would i would love to
see that right because i feel like dr
dean would be very haughty about the
kind of pizza he eats but regardless
once iron man shows up on the scene you
do get this moment here where everyone's
like okay we have to make sure he keeps
his guard down we got to make sure he
stays relaxed chill and then we'll
activate our weapon and we'll siphon
this power off of him right like we'll
take this power away from him and then
he'll be back to being normal tony stark
and so as this goes on patsy walker just
gets more and more fed up because the
reality is she's thinking it all right
she knows that like tony stark's thing
at the moment is to basically like
everybody is just ingratiating
themselves to him and so she pretends to
do that as well but ultimately all
pretense goes out the window she snaps
and just starts screaming at him and
that's when he realizes everybody's
faking it now where silver surfer and
doctor doom step in to do what they can
in the end it's not enough and using the
sheer amount of power at his disposal he
basically kills everybody except for
patsy walker and this is where things
get really really cool and it's what i
love about christopher cantwell's work
it's one thing to have a writer that's
just like in this comic book iron man
becomes god and does some stuff and then
the story's done thanks for reading like
it's one thing to do that right because
i've read those stories a million times
what i do love is when we get a blend we
get a blend of tony stark basically as
god using the power of god and then in
turn we get a more in-depth character
analysis to this and so once of course
he's basically destroyed everybody patsy
walker steps up and that's when iron man
has to come has to come to the
realization he's literally the villain
here like he's the bad guy of this story
he killed everybody that ever meant
anything to him and so what you end up
getting is this point where patsy
walker's like we need to talk and uh and
tony stark essentially teleports their
minds of course their physical bodies
are in the same place but teleports
their mind to a place where when he was
younger he was always sent to by his dad
right kind of sent away and he would
just kind of spend time there where he
had literally just this gigantic chunk
of land where he had everything he
needed except for the thing that
mattered the most which really was his
father and that's why you have this
great discussion here that goes on
between the two because in a lot of ways
it's so relatable that one of the things
he says is like well you know yes i get
that i killed everybody but with my
power i can bring them back right i can
make it like it never happened and
that's when patsy walker is like that's
the problem tony stark you're operating
as if there's no consequences for your
actions the truth about this is that
yeah you could make it so it never
happened but it did happen you did kill
everybody and that's the problem right
and so that's when stark's like i just
wanted to make things better right i
just i just wanted to make the world a
better place but patsy walker's not
buying but she's not buying this kind of
false false not really even him just
being fake him offering just what he
believes to be the right explanation
instead of the truthful explanation and
she's like that's not the reason why you
did what you did it's not the reason why
you took the power of of the you know
took the power cosmic and did all this
tried to make the world better and so on
and so forth that's not why all this has
happened she's like give me the real
reason for why it happened and his
response is so i can feel something
other than worthless and this is a
phenomenal thing because as i was
reading through this right one i felt
this you know like there are times
believe it or not guys there are times
when despite my success i do feel
worthless
because oftentimes how we feel on a very
deep and personal level goes far beyond
the things that we could buy or acquire
to somehow fix that and the mistake we
make as people is buying or acquiring
things to try to fix that just to
believe we can somehow fill this hole
this need that we need satisfied on a
personal level that cannot be satisfied
by the things we own that tony stark
looks at himself and sees all of his
total accomplishments as netting to zero
that they don't have any value
whatsoever he says if i wasn't achieving
and winning i wasn't if i wasn't the
absolute best then to my father i was
invisible like i didn't matter like i
was totally irrelevant here where he
asked patsy walker he says like do you
know the story of jekyll and hyde she
was like yeah i mean there's the good
one the bad one he's like no that's not
the actual story of jekyll and hyde and
what you get here is this great
juxtaposition between tony stark and
iron man and what he says is for dr
jekyll he's a good person like he's fun
he's smart he's dutiful right you know
whatever but flawed just like everybody
else but he starts to wonder if he
should rid himself of these vices right
of his lesser qualities because the
truth is he can't stand those lesser
qualities about himself of course with
tony stark he's referencing his own
gambling addiction his alcoholism by his
desire to kind of put on this flaunt to
be the center of attention all the time
and he says deep down he hates them he
hates these weaker parts of himself so
he can cox a unique and a special method
something that will allow him to be the
paragon that he's always wanted to be he
can be perfect now no distractions no
errors but of course the bad stuff about
him the ugly selfish stuff it's still
there but now it's relegated to a
separate part of himself a self that
doesn't really think about or even care
about things anymore it doesn't really
matter to him who this self hurts in the
process because now he gets to be a
saint just like he's always secretly
wanted to be now before we continue on
this is beautifully handled and i love
the way this is done by christopher
cantwell because what it basically gives
us is this idea is that tony stark is
hurting on a personal level because to
the person that mattered the most to him
right his caregiver his father he was
irrelevant unless he was perfect in
every conceivable way and the reality is
that those kind of expectations thrust
onto a child by their parent it creates
all kinds of complexes because the
reality is that nobody's perfect it's an
impossible goal to achieve but by
setting the bar in a place that can
never be achieved it leads to people
becoming perfectionists that's what i am
i'm a perfectionist like to me it's not
okay to make mistakes it's not okay to
be wrong now one of the benefits of my
youtube channel here and one of the
things that i've learned over the time
in being a youtuber is that it's okay to
be wrong i've been wrong multiple times
on this channel i've i've told you guys
like hey look i make mistakes sometimes
right like i mean trying to run off 25
years of comic book history from memory
you're gonna make mistakes
right like you're gonna make errors it's
just the nature of things and over time
i've learned to accept that i've learned
to accept that fact you guys watching
this video you struggle with the exact
same thing right these interpersonal
struggles as a result of your childhood
experience things like that that
ultimately shape you and make you who
you are and so it's beautiful the way
that it's done because what he says what
tony stark says is that despite this
belief that as iron man he's just this
perfect paragon in the end he's not he's
still just some misguided person he
continues to do bad things his flaws
remain and people get hurt right the
civil war event the evolutionary war the
whole thing with the death of captain
america in the aftermath of civil war he
says his grand transformation process it
starts to lose its effectiveness it's
potency he tries drinking more of the
potion to make it work and it simply
just doesn't the flaws become abscesses
but he keeps reaching even as perfection
slips further and further away he goes
for broke but it just gets worse rinse
and repeat and it's that this idea that
no matter what he does to try to become
this perfect person that nothing ever
works and the reason why is because he's
chasing an impossible perception that
was thrust on him when he was a kid and
turned into a core part of him he's
still chasing the approval of his father
and it doesn't exist one because his
dad's dead and two there's no way for
him to get it because the expectations
that howard stark had on tony were
impossible to achieve expectations and
so the more he tries the harder he tries
the more and more he screws up and so
what he ends up doing is basically
resurrecting everybody right repairing
them fixing them so you know in the end
they're all just like they were before
but they also remember everything he
makes his promises or he makes his makes
his apologies and then he gets rid of
his power cosmic he literally just lets
it go away now the kicker to all this
and this is what's so interesting here
is there comes a point as he's walking
through central park where he's actually
held up by a guy with a knife and he
just ultimately hands his wallet over
there was a time when he could have just
simply willed that guy out of existence
and that's what's so ironic about this
that's what makes it so such an
interesting thing is by undoing
everything he's done a credible argument
can be made that he actually made the
world worse right letting the world go
back to the way that it was violence and
destruction and death at the hands of
people who relish in those things or who
were on desperate times themselves
seeking only to fulfill their own
individual desires was the world really
worse off when tony stark had done what
he done was the world a genuinely better
place it just takes a little while for
the dust to settle and to realize that's
the case i mean after all you can't make
an omelet without breaking a few eggs
and that's one of the interesting things
about this is on a more philosophical
level one of the things that we've
talked about is that superheroes are not
there to make up and make the world a
better place superheroes exist to
maintain the status quo and as soon as
somebody comes along that can change the
status quo suddenly superheroes rebel
the reality is that change is painful
and change often costs lives it's just
the way things go there are those who
resist change and those who satisfy
change of course the loss of life is
relative to the scope of the change
that's being made but in the end that
loss of life can happen the question you
have to ask is do the ends justify the
means and that's usually always the
question that gets asked right that's
usually always the case right there was
a massive technological social upheaval
after the events of world war ii but it
took world war ii to reach to that point
right millions of lives lost but
humanity stepped into what was arguably
for a time a better age a more
technologically advanced age and
depending on where you were in the world
a more economic enlightened or
economically enlightened age so again
it's one of those interesting concepts
where it's just kind of like were things
really that terrible you know or is it
one of those one of those things where
it's like ultron said in avengers 2 you
know you want to save the world but you
don't want it to change one of those two
things those two things cannot exist at
the same time and so ultimately one of
the other things that tony stark have
been dealing with is remember there was
a huge point in time like right up until
the moment when he became the iron god
where his neck was broken if you guys if
you guys remember that he was walking
around with a broken neck and so he was
literally just injecting himself
automatically with morphine all the time
which means now suddenly without the
without the power that he had before
he's literally going through morphine
withdrawal then while he did use his
powers to repair his neck right so he's
not walking around with a broken neck
anymore his body was had had to withdraw
or has to go through the morphine
withdrawal process and in doing that he
literally just starts to fall apart
right i mean it's shaking it's hitting
in waves you talk to anybody out there
who has gone through any kind of drug
induced withdrawal and they will tell
you it turns your life upside down right
inside out it's some of the most
physical you know some of the worst
physical and emotional pain that you're
ever going to experience the crazy thing
is that in the midst of all this michael
korvac reappears
michael corbett pops back up because
remember the last we saw of him it was
the living tribunal and the cosmic
abstracts that had whisked him away to
basically imprison him for the things
that he'd done but what he had said is
none of those guys could hold the living
tribunal the in-betweener none of those
guys could keep me in check now we don't
know if he's really telling the truth or
kind of manipulating in a lot of ways
when it came to michael korvac it was
very much that way that michael korvac
is just kind of been a king of
manipulation lies and deceit since his
reintroduction in uh in christopher
cantwell's run but when he starts
taunting tony stark and saying like i
have this genius idea that i had to
share with you right what i realized
here is that the reason why i couldn't
fix the universe is because there were
people who stood against me so i'm just
gonna get rid of it right i'm gonna i'm
gonna become cancel culture silence
people who disagree with me or whose
opinions i don't agree with right like
that's exactly what he's what he's
advocating here and so in the end he's
like isn't it gonna be beautiful stark
the only people who will exist are the
people who agree with me everybody else
will be silenced or gone and of course
tony stark is basically passed out right
he can't really hear any of what's going
on right now you know because he's going
through morphine withdrawal and so what
happens is when michael korvac wakes him
up stark challenges korvak with his own
personal revelation where he says or he
literally tells him he was like you know
i know the story of you michael korvac
we have ever since the original
quarterback saga when you first popped
up and we as the avengers teamed up with
the guardians of the galaxy from the
31st century we know your story that you
are a human being who was raised on an
earth that had been conquered by the
badoon following the slaughter of
billions of people but let me ask you
something right like like let me ask you
a question what deal did you make in
order to keep yourself alive and that's
when korvac just kind of starts lashing
out and he's like i simply just want to
say here right i just want to want to
ask this question here when it came to
this to you acquiring all this absolute
power the question i have is why you
know how long has it been since you've
been afraid to lose since you've been
scared to lose he said since the
beginning i'm betting since when just
being yourself just some guy meant a
painfully and ultimately ignominious
death he says look i get it most of the
time i wear a bunch of metal just to
feel just to feel real and even then the
metal the armor it's not enough he says
i thought you were full of crap with
your whole crusade but then i went and
got some cosmic power for myself and i
realized it didn't work it didn't fix
anything and so that's really what both
michael korvac and tony stark struggle
with and i love that that christopher
cantwell kind of brought these two
together in this way and said their
stories are not that dissimilar because
of his own personal experiences michael
korvac never came to believe that being
himself was okay he never came to
believe that he was fine the way he was
by any number of circumstances he came
to believe that there was something
wrong with him and for a lot of us as
people that's what we endure on a
regular basis right like you're a guy
and you're in you know middle school or
high school and you're asking girls out
and you're getting shot down at every
single turn every time you ask a girl
out you get turned down despite what the
world will tell you that will impact
your self-image right it doesn't mean
that people are going out of their way
to tear down your self-image but they
would be idiots to believe that it
doesn't and so that hits your confidence
that hits your self-image and to simply
say well you know you just gotta take it
and stride right what it's basically
doing is it's telling you how you feel
doesn't matter how you feel is
irrelevant right you just got to tough
it up and you got to keep on keeping on
right that's why you get to a point
where a lot of guys get to a point where
they just bow out right they just stop
asking women out they stop dating and
they go and live their lives and what
they find is they discover a level of
happiness that they had never
experienced before because now their
ability to be happy is not predicated on
being you know on on dating somebody
else it's not predicated on somebody
else's uh you know positive opinions of
them that instead it's just them living
their life and leaving everything else
behind for a lot of women it's the exact
same way because women get rejected too
right easier for girls to find dates
easier for men to form relationships and
so it's just one of those things where
over the course of our lives and not
even just the dating scene in the job
world right interpersonal relationships
friendships things like that that over
time over the course of our life we can
oftentimes experience things that will
make us feel worthless it'll make us
feel like we don't matter and if we take
that and we roll with it and what we
look for is some external validation to
tell us that we do then we'll follow the
path of tony stark and michael korvak
jumping from one grand scheme to the
next and never finding any measure of
satisfaction there because the truth is
that our struggle is internal not
external and so again it's a it's a
beautifully handled you know piece of
writing here i love the way that
christopher cantwell did this and so
what tony stark does is he challenges
korvac he's like stop being this guy
stop being this guy that's attaining the
power cosmic or somehow controlling the
world's electricity grid or trying to
become god because at the end of the day
no matter what you do you're still going
to be the same michael korvak you always
were you're the guy who's running the
guy who doesn't want to be you because
you were told every moment of your life
that being you is not okay there's
something wrong with who you are and you
need to be somebody other than who you
are if you want other people to accept
you right if you want to fit in right
now granted that was the extreme nature
of michael korvak growing up in the
sense that being a human was basically a
death sentence and so that's why he's
always achieved some measure of godhood
and a desire to transcend beyond his
humanity but that's when tony stark is
like be a man right like get rid of all
this and just be a guy or are you scared
and that's when korvac just lets go of
all of his cosmic power and reverts
himself back to being just a normal
human guy and then of course ends up
just beating the crap out of tony stark
and as the two of them not even really
tony stark putting up a fight right as
he's getting absolutely pummeled that
when michael korvac asks like what's
happening to you the response of stark
is you know how i said the armor the
cosmos how none of it was enough he says
yeah i've always or i'm always looking
for something more and he says what i've
been using lately these drugs to keep
going and to stay strong that in the end
that's not gonna work out either and
it's made me pretty damn sick and to be
quite frank i'm probably gonna die here
unless you kill me first and so michael
korvac kind of looking at that and
realizing that tony stark is a dying man
but at the same time the fact that tony
stark in his seemingly final moments was
so selfless in a way that he made
michael korvac face a part of himself
that he just refused to face if at the
very least make him feel some measure of
acceptance michael korvac for reasons
that are never really explained to tony
stark picks him up and then carries him
to a hospital and then when he does
michael korvac goes to the top of a
building jumps off seemingly takes
himself out and so what you end up
getting is like you know kind of a one
week later time skip and you have tony
stark who is taken by uh patsy walker to
what looks to be a rehab clinic and this
is cool because it's basically tony
stark getting the kind of help he needs
in order to overcome what he's
struggling with but the cool thing about
this is that it's not really tony stark
doing what he's done before which is
essentially him you know admitting he's
an alcoholic like he did in civil war or
anything along those lines instead it's
more than simply just his addiction to
various things drugs alcohol so on and
so forth instead what it is is him
treating what's going on inside of him
so he can basically bring these things
to an end come to some measure of inner
peace it's cool and i think it's
beautifully done right so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end i don't know if christopher
cantwell's run is gonna continue on
after this honestly i haven't looked it
up i really hope it does because i'll be
quite honest with you this is one of the
best like iron man comic book runs that
i've ever read it was beautifully done i
absolutely loved it but thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace
you